justice secretary robert buckland is
here with me this morning good morning
good morning
nice to see you some figures to start
with if i may
um some saying many people saying the
rise in demand was predictable
85 of the population unable to get a
test yesterday if they wanted one 46
out of the 48 hot spots in the united
kingdom in
england no facilities how difficult can
it be
when we knew it was coming to make sure
that this is happening
well look i think that uh all of us are
seeing these difficulties
uh i think that as the schools have come
back as families have tried to get back
to normal with work and child care
the complications of life really make
things much more challenging and i think
that
well i think that frankly we have worked
so hard to scale up capacity we're still
not there
but the rate of increase is remarkable
it's now outstripping other european
countries
what i would say is that i think it's
incumbent on all of us
to do the right thing for our family
but remember that you know there are a
lot of other people out there who need
those tests
i think the lab capacity laboratory
capacity has been an issue we're working
our way through that
we're increasing the number of test
centers we've got 400
test centers getting it up to 500 but
clearly they're still
real challenges and i don't see five
percent of the population
and and i understand that i'm not sort
of trying to shy away
from the scale of the challenge but you
know when you get
the test the return rate is very good
it's the 90
coming back the day after and that's
good and quick but
i think the announcement by matt hancock
yesterday to create a prioritization
system is the right thing to do now he's
going to develop
that very quickly over the next few days
to explain to us
what that looks like but i think all of
us who know and have been here through
testing and you you've asked me some
searching questions in the past about
this
we'll know that it has to be the nhs
first and then social care
and then i think what we need to do is
have a cascading system where we know
where our priorities should be and for
me priorities should be for
children in school and their parents in
order to make sure that their lives
uh are safe and also importantly they're
not disrupted in the way that we're
seeing we were told that the government
allocated 10 billion pounds for test and
trace systems
for for england 100 times the public
health
england's annual budget for infectious
diseases
what have we spent it on well i i think
we've spent it as
quickly and as sensibly as possible on
getting the system
of the population can't get a test well
okay i'm not shying away
from the current 10 billion quid i'm not
shying away from that but what i'm
trying to explain is that rather than us
sitting back and pretending all is well
we've accepted the scale of the
challenge we're ramping up the test
centers
we have increased laboratory capacity
new labs coming
on streams so that we can get that quick
turnaround
it wasn't just a surprise the second
wave wasn't a surprise well
and in fact the government kept on
saying about the dangers of a second
wave
at all times the prime minister all of
us uh were
absolutely focused on the dangers of a
second wave we've seen what's happening
in france
uh we absolutely are on to this in terms
of
understanding that through the autumn if
we're to get the balance between
uh getting the economy back on track and
getting our children into school
then all of us have know a special
responsibility
to follow all those guidelines and do
whatever it takes to beat this virus
minister you're a decent man
how difficult is it to come on the
program and defend the government's
response
well look i'm here as a government
minister and i take full
responsibility what i would say is that
i think that
uh the government has absolutely
committed not just money but resources
time the energy that is needed but you
could do better scale
a lot better okay we can always do
better but the rate
of increase is now outstripping
countries like germany and other
europeans we don't care my viewers don't
care well
they don't care they care about the fact
that 85 percent of them can't get a test
and you the government you in the you
know in the shape of the government this
morning are coming on and saying
we're doing our level best it's not good
enough well i i would say that the the
uh the rate and pace of increase is uh
really
positive and i know that minister 85
of the population can't get a test
that's not good enough but we
as i've explained to you we've already
taken we're already taking the measures
testing centers on laboratory capacity
all the things
well i i'm sorry i do not agree i think
that the
issues that we are now facing with
regard to the way in which
uh the rules are applied have created
this increased demand
uh and uh we are absolutely committed
to uh making sure that we can deal with
these problems
and minimize the disruption that is
being caused
um talk to me about the um
the internal market bill it depends what
you call it as to which newspaper you're
reading this morning
apparently that you've been involved in
negotiating with the prime minister
um and also um one of the tory rebels
bob neal to try and come up with a way
through
this melee have you well i don't think
it'd be right to me to start talking
about
private conversations have you been
involved with private what i can say is
there are lots of discussions going on
with mps from all parts of the debate
not just bob neal but
mps on all part in all parts of the
conservative party we want to
get on with this job we want to get this
bill through we want to make sure that
we are ready for any uh disagreements or
disputes that might arise if we don't
get agreement in the joint committee
and that's what we're planning on you
know for me i just want brexit sorted
the issue was that the issue you asked
me the top of the program
is the important one to me to my family
and to all the people who are watching
and that's covered and the needs it will
be a big issue as well of course going
forward and you need to plan for that
have you been having conversations with
bob neal
you can tell me i talked to bob deal
have you been having conversations with
bob neal about the internal marketing
i i have talked to bob dylan about the
internal market bill have you spoken to
the prime minister
about your conversations with bob neal
about the internal market okay
it's tempting look i've had lots of
conversations i'm not asking what you
said i'm just asking whether you've got
a conversation i've had lots of
conversations with colleagues
ultimately what about the prime minister
it is up to the prime minister
and those responsible for business in
parliament we want to know that you're
doing your best
well look i always do my best to try and
get things sorted that's the sort of
person i am i'm trying to help get a
solution
but it's not all down to me it's down to
every a member of the conservative party
member of parliament
to come together and get this sorted now
i heard you
at the weekend talking about uh whether
we might break the law or not and you
obviously know i was going to ask you
about this
if the government enacts the bill then
we could potentially be breaking
international law
does that make your position untenable
well
as i said on the weekend i don't think
we are at that stage
and you know well if we reach that stage
the reason for it is because we judge
that sadly
despite everybody's best efforts the eu
is in a position where we think they
are actually breaching their obligations
to us so it's like an international
dispute
where clearly there's a breach somewhere
but it's going to be the subject of a
lot of argument now i'd like to avoid
that
i think we can but we do need to just
prepare for that contingency that break
glass in case of emergency provision
that i believe this is given your job qc
if we break the law does that make your
position on turnover
if this country breaks the law and does
so
uh you know in a way that uh is clear uh
and in a way that uh you know is it
cannot be
judged uh uh you know finally or or
fudged in any way
or
yeah no i get that but there are lots of
debates about precisely
what the law means in this area i've
said that if the law is breached in a
way that i find unacceptable of course
i will go but i do not believe we're at
that stage
i think that we can resolve this i think
that
there's a will certainly on the side of
the united kingdom to get on with this
negotiation but at the end of the day
we've got to protect our united kingdom
and our internal market
and frankly there's no uh dispute about
that i think any conservative mp
faced with that sort of crisis that
emergency would want to invoke the
provisions that we
are seeking to pass okay jeremy right
and jeffrey cox both think
that it's unconscionable that this
country should just be famous for its
regard for the rule of law around the
world
should act in the way that we are well i
think
my colleagues are absolutely right to
sound the alarm
about a flagrant and egregious breach
of the rule of law something that is
beyond any doubt or
uh argument uh i don't believe i don't
but yeah but i do not
i do not believe that we're there we're
not at that stage we're at a stage where
we would resign before we got there
look i i think that if we got to the
stage where clearly there was uh
uh the united kingdom was in a position
where it had
not discharged its obligations then that
would cause me a problem
i don't believe we're going to get there
because i see this government united
kingdom as
doing everything they can to discharge
their obligations to do the right thing
to act in good faith
but to protect the integrity of us of
our internal market
you've answered all my questions i
appreciate it we've got two very quick
questions
before we let you go we're almost out of
time the reason that you're here today
sentencing overhaul
anymore yes so i'm publishing a white
paper as a policy paper to explain the
government's position and then we can
pass laws to enact that uh i want to uh
deal first of all with some of the more
serious cases so uh whole life that is
life-meaning life for child killers
i want to increase the maximum penalty
for causing death by dangerous driving
from 14 years
to life so quite a lot of important
changes that will increase confidence i
want to
extend the time for which serious
violent and sexual offenders
actually serve in prison so that the
public feel that my higher degree of
justice is done
but i'm also going to reform the
probation service strengthen community
orders and give the public and judges
more confidence
that when a community order is passed
it'll actually make a difference
and help people who want to take that
help away from a life of crime so lots
in this package
to try and deal with uh more lower level
offending but also
to toughen up and tighten up very
sensitive very serious points goodness a
lot for you to do let's hope we don't
break the law and then you can stay in
post
um obviously the abbot question is
coming
kevin rudd is on the programme later on
today he lost his position
as australian prime minister to tony
abbott
he says tony abbott is the single most
destructive politician in modern
australian
politics that's a senior australian
politician saying that about him are you
totally comfortable with a climate
change denier
representing us on the world stage what
can i say i've never met tony abbott
i don't it's amazing he's not got many
friends in government i don't know how
he got elected i i don't know
i mean i i don't agree with him on
issues like climate change i
certainly don't agree with some of his
reported views
about lbg lbgt rights uh
however i do know that he was prime
minister of a major
trading nation in in the southern
hemisphere
he does have experience of trade deals
uh frankly we should be harnessing the
part-time advice and support of people
with those with that sort of background
uh but i must say that i think that that
doesn't mean that the government is
therefore bound to agree
with the uh the the the world view
uh of uh every person saying child was
well you know there's lots of people we
can take advice from on certain things
but we can also say well
on other matters we disagree prime
minister was clear about that
i'm certainly clear about that and
frankly you know
he is best confined to giving advice
about trade
and whilst he's got his right to express
his view i don't think the government
will be following
his view in other respects yeah
california's burning and he's a climate
change
well i i look up doesn't you just have
to hold your nose and accept that
he's good at trade i i i um you know his
views on climate change are matter for
him
they're not the views of the of the
government we're not asking for his
advice on climate change
we're asking for his advice on trade uh
and that's it oh we're out of time i'd
love to chat to you for much longer we
do something on a wednesday called um
a quick question where our viewers can
ask questions directly
it takes about 20 minutes will you come
back and do one of those for us at some
stage it sounds
fun actually okay is that a yes yeah
let's see what we can do fantastic we're
all busy but let's i would
be happy to oblige you fantastic